das wasserproblem auf der erde scheint
gelöst wenn es wirklich funktioniert
gibt es genügend trinkwasser für alle
auf der erde sogar in sehr trockenen
gebieten könnten menschen überlegen wie
wasser fast überall aus der luft
gewonnen werden kann jetzt bei chief
science fiction herzlich willkommen
wasser ist ein kostbares gut das haben
inzwischen leider auch unternehmen
festgestellt unternehmen wie nestlé
packen weltweit wasser ab und verkaufen
es teuer
während in den gleichen ländern die
menschen nicht genug trinkwasser haben
in anderen teilen der welt wie zum
beispiel dem iran wird raubbau am wasser
betrieben dort werden jedes jahr 110
prozent der niederschlagsmenge
verbraucht das sind 90 prozent punkte zu
viel und sogar 30 prozent mehr als eine
wasserkrise die unempfindlich mehr als
20 prozent der niederschlagsmenge zu
verbrauchen möglich wird das dort
übrigens sogar als fossiles trinkwasser
verbraucht wird das nicht ersetzt wird
der iran wird gezwungenermaßen
verkauften zu einer hitzigen wüste der
nächste krieg ums wasser scheint dort
unabwendbar das ist schlimm
jetzt haben us forscher wahrscheinlich
die technik entwickelt um überall wasser
so bin nämlich aus der luft ihr habt es
vielleicht selbst schon mal erlebt die
luft ist so richtig feucht warm und an
allem was kalt ist kondensiert das
wasser die ursache ist ganz einfach das
gasförmige wasser in der luft wird
flüssig wenn es kalt wird
der umgekehrte vorgang des kochens stadt
gasförmig geht es vom gasförmigen in den
flüssigen zustand über und man kann es
trinken
leider ist nur selten so viel wasser in
der luft und die temperatur unterschiede
so groß dass das funktioniert zudem
braucht man für die technische umsetzung
meistens eine menge energie
amerikanische forscher haben jetzt aber
ein verfahren entwickelt bei dem das
immer oder fast immer funktioniert und
zudem mit nur wenig energie
die luft braucht dabei sogar nur 20
prozent wasser zu enthalten
und dann funktionieren forscher um john
hocking vom massachusetts institute of
technology kurz in den usa haben jetzt
ein verfahren entwickelt das lediglich
mit sonnenenergie funktioniert des
rätsels lösung ist aber ein sehr poröse
substrate in dem das wasser leicht
kondensieren kann amoled 01 heißt es
unterschied aus dem mittag zirkonium
einer wasserstoff sauerstoff bin
und dem salz der human säure dieser
stoff hat unzählige pure damit eine
riesige oberfläche auf der das wasser
kondensieren kann dabei funktioniert das
schon bei 25 grad celsius also zum
beispiel in der nacht in sehr heißen
region tagsüber bringt durch eine
glasplatte liegt auf das substrat und
erhitzt es auf 65 grad das wasser
verdunstet aus dem substrat und kann
gesammelt werden
pro kilogramm des substrats können so
zwei wasser setzte trockenen regionen
mit 20 durch feuchtigkeit gesammelt
werden ein durchbruch
wir halten euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden was die entwicklung angeht
sie könnte tatsächlich in vielen
regionen das trinkwasser problem lösen
und wenn er nicht zu diesem thema
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und gehen wir danach noch
einen auf die glocke und das was er
bisher ihre verletzung verpasst habt das
seht ihr jetzt hier in der best of play
list also einfach draufklicken und
ansonsten bis dann